you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
you can dislike Sony's PlayStation it
was a machine that brought us countless
hours of fun and was ahead of its time
but assuring in the 3d era of console
gaming but where did the PlayStation
come from and what's the story behind it
for the first time on ColdFusion this
episode will be centered around Sony
let's take a look at the story the
PlayStation all started with one man ken
Kutaragi a Sony engineer ken first
became interested in working in
videogames in 1988 after seeing his
daughter play games on Nintendo's
Entertainment System console full of
inspiration
ken approached Nintendo to create a
cd-rom drive for their upcoming Super
Nintendo system the new drive was to be
called the super disc Nintendo agreed
and Ken brought together a research and
development team with insane in 1990 the
following year at CES Sony would show
off the Nintendo compatible Super disc
now codenamed
the PlayStation it was a multimedia
powerhouse capable of not only playing
Nintendo games but also audio CDs data
CDs and video CDs a pretty big deal for
unfortunately for Sony disaster was
around the corner just one day later
Nintendo would surprise everyone with an
announcement they announced that they
would break their partnership with
saying in making the Super disc and
partner would philips instead to work
towards the same technology this made
the president of Sony norio ogre furious
even more unfortunately for Ken other
employees within Sony thought that the
idea of entering the videogame industry
was a bad idea and they let him know
about it in 1992 a meeting was held
within Sony to discuss the future of the
PlayStation the concept was very close
to being scrapped but Ken reminded norio
of how Nintendo had dishonored the
company while the world was watching
nor even agreed to let the playstation
project continue however the older
generation of Sony executives was still
very unhappy about Sony entering the
videogame industry this force can and
his newly formed team to leave Sony's
main headquarters and continue work at
Sony Music headquarters with the
groundwork for the new projects ordered
Sony had a choice to make
should this console focus on 2d graphics
or 3d polygon graphics while the team
are contemplating this dilemma a new
gaming phenomena was taking over
Japanese arcades it was Virtua Fighter a
3d polygons game by Sega the Sony team
now had their answer not long after this
in 1993 Sony Computer Entertainment
would be formed out of the CEO of Sony
Music and Ken could arrive himself the
involvement of Sony Music was actually a
blessing in disguise as the marketing
creative talent and manufacturing of the
discs could be done in-house saving both
time and money the following year in a
Tokyo hotel Sony would showcase some
technical demos the technical demo
showed in the hotel session were good
enough to open the floodgates for keen
developers big players like Electronic
Arts and Namco were now interested so
what caused all of this interest the
PlayStation had solid 3d graphics and
most importantly CD capabilities which
are a major step above present-day
cartridges in December of 1994 the
PlayStation was let loose in Japan its
main competition was the Sega Saturn
never really that was a loud
fluid and free in real-time 3d never not
anywhere but especially not on that
other system simply because with only
one processor it doesn't have the power
to do
fly plaything fly you're not already
yeah sales for both consoles started off
strong but despite this the Sega Saturn
ultimately proved to be a failure the
main reasons being that the PlayStation
sold for cheaper and was also much
easier to develop for meaning many more
games than the Sega Saturn a Playstation
worldwide release would occur in 1995
and popularity soared the PlayStation
would be the first console to cross 100
million sales and would go on to become
an iconic consumer product of the 1990s
not even the Nintendo 64 could dampen
the success of the Sony machine the
PlayStation successor the cleverly
titled PlayStation 2 would be the
best-selling home console of all time
selling 155 million units as time went
on the PlayStation 3 & 4 would both be
Smash Hits solidifying Sony as a leader
in living room entertainment being
rejected by Nintendo turned out to be
one of the greatest things that happened
to Sony all right so before we wrap up
the video for all your knowledge seekers
out there let's take a look at five fun
facts about the original playstation
number five
have you ever wondered what the square
triangle o and X actually mean well
let's take a look the triangle
represents the players point of view the
square represents a piece of paper for
menus and in-game documents the O means
yes and the X means no but funnily
enough in western markets this was
reversed number four the first major
Sony developed game was motor toon Grand
Prix by a small team called Polly's
Polly's would go on to become polyphony
digital the creator of the legendary
Gran Turismo series number three in 1994
Namco developed a test board called
system 11 to simulate the PlayStation
one during development
the first major title to use this board
was a test program for a fighting game
to experiment with textures on 3d
characters this experiment would
eventually turn into one of the most
legendary games of all time
tekken a key playstation hit number two
the best-selling game of the playstation
was Gran Turismo shifting over 10
million units this is followed by Final
Fantasy 7 Resident Evil Tekken 3 Tomb
Raider and crash bandicoot number 1 so
what about ken kutaragi today he serves
as the president and CEO of an Internet
service company called cyber AI
Entertainment Inc last year Ken received
a Lifetime Achievement Award at the 2014
game developer conference nice to see
that he's still doing stuff good on you
can it's pretty cool that even though
people hated Ken's idea and another
company betrayed him he's still stuck
with it forever changing the course of
gaming history anyway that was just a
bit of Technology history for you I
hoped you liked this video and if you
did give it a thumbs up and subscribe if
you're new feel free to leave a comment
of your favorite PlayStation memory this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll see you again soon
for the next video cold fusion
it's rethinking